we're told the triangle a prime B prime
C prime so that's this red triangle over
here is the image of triangle ABC so
that's this blue triangle here under
rotation about the origin so we're
rotating about the origin here determine
the angle of rotation so like always
pause this video see if you can figure
it out so I'm just gonna think about
what how did each of these points have
to be rotated to go from a to a prime or
be it a B prime or from C to C prime so
let's just start with a so this is where
a starts remember we're rotating about
the origin that's why I'm drawing this
line from the origin to a and where does
it get rotated to well it gets rotated
to right over here so the rotation is
going in the counterclockwise direction
so it's going to have a positive angle
so we can rule out these two right over
here and the key question is is is this
30 degrees or 60 degrees and there's a
bunch of ways that you could think about
it 160 degrees would be two-thirds of a
right angle while 30 degrees would be
one-third of a right angle a right angle
would look something like this so this
looks much more like two-thirds of a
right angle so I'll go with 60 degrees
another way to think about it is that 60
degrees is one-third of 180 degrees
which this also looks like right over
here and if you do that with any of the
points you would see a similar thing so
just looking at aid a prime makes me
feel good that this was a 60 degree
rotation let's do another example so we
are told quadrilateral a prime B prime C
prime D prime in red here is the image
of quadrilateral ABCD in blue here under
rotation about point Q determine the
angle of rotation so once again pause
this video and see if you can figure it
out well I'm going to tackle this the
same way I don't have a coordinate plane
here but it's the same notion I can take
some initial point and then look at its
image and think about well how much did
I have to rotate it I could do B to B
prime although this might be a little
bit too close so we're going from B to
let me do it a new color here just cuz
it's this color is too close to I'll use
black so we're going from B to B prime
right over here
we are going clockwise so it's going to
be a negative rotation so we can rule
that and that out and it looks like a
right angle this looks like a right
angle so I feel good about picking
negative 90 degrees we could try another
point and feel good that that also meets
that negative 90 degrees let's say D to
D prime so this is where D is initially
this is where D is and this is where D
prime is and once again we are moving
clockwise so it's a negative rotation
and this looks like a right angle
definitely more like a right angle than
a 60 degree angle and so this would be
negative 90 degrees definitely feel good
about that